sur le ministre ma question porte sur
l'effort entreprise par la nation pour
revaloriser le secteur médico-social qui
a été en première ligne durant la
pandémie et sur certains angles morts
qu'il nous reste avec je pense ainsi à
ceux que l'on appelle les oubliés du
Ségur c'est professionnel des services
logistiques techniques ou administratifs
qui représentent un maillon essentiel du
service médico-social notre
reconnaissance doit s'adresser à toute
la chaîne humaine sans exception or
contrairement à leurs collègues
soignants ou éducateurs ces personnels
demeurent exclus des primes décidées
dans le cadre du Ségur de la santé les
183 euros nets mensuels accordés en plus
ne sont toujours pas pour eux cette
situation est vécue comme une réelle
injustice par ces femmes et ses hommes
agents d'entretien et de maintenance
secrétaire agent d'accueil comptable
ressources humaines ou équipe de cuisine
une partie des professionnels à
bénéficier d'un rattrapage du Ségur mais
uniquement pour certaines catégories
ayant un lieu un lien avec la santé et
l'accompagnement direct infirmier
psychologue moniteur d'ateliers
continuer à exclure une partie du
médico-social revient à instaurer un
système à deux vitesses toutes les
professions utiles au fonctionnement des
établissements et services de santé sont
garants de la bonne prise en charge des
patients et des usagers au sein de ces
institutions c'est d'autant plus
incompréhensible que ces professionnels
éducatifs et d'accompagnement sont
financés par l'assurance maladie les
conseils départementaux et l'État via
les ARS monsieur le ministre comment le
gouvernement compte il accompagner la
prise en charge de ces angles morts sur
les différents échelons y compris
territoriales pour enfin mettre toutes
ces personnes sur un pied d'égalité et
leur accorder cette reconnaissance
unanime qu'elle mérite toutes je vous en
remercie